vous êtes très émotif hein ouais ben
c'està-dire qu'il est émotif dans un
certain sens il estmotif en haut mais
pas en
bas mais vous pouvez vraiment avoir de
la tendresse sur un un film X mais au
départ c'est toute une question de
feeling quoi c'est moi j'essaie toujours
de de connaître un petit peu mes
partenaires de parce que c'est vrai de
but en blanc comme ça passer à l'action
c'est pas je je préfère quand même
discuter avec elle la connaître un petit
peu et et c'est vrai qu'on a plus facile
à se mettre dans la peau du personnage
quoi c'est vrai que là vous êtes tout
mignon tout jeune enfin on ne voit pas
la suite hein on s'arrête là on a on a
l'impression d'un d'un film gentillet
érotique c'est c'est rarement comme ça
quand même c'est rarement comme ça oui
je trouve ça dommage un petit peu alors
tous les deux vous êtes de tout jeune
comédien du X ça fait vous un peu plus
d'un an Sébastien vous euh un peu Mo un
peu moins vous êtes tout nouveau dans le
métier comment vous êtes arrivé à ce
métier alors donc vous vous étiez sapeur
pompier ouais tout à fait vous
Titof câur monteur câur ou monteur câur
donc vous escaladiez vous les les
pylones voilà j'étais tout en haut
j'étais tout en haut tout en haut des
pylones euh dans le nord de la France
tous les deux vous êtes vous êtes des
des amis tout à fait est-ce qu'on peut
avoir pour ambition de devenir justement
une star du du X pas pas une star du X
de faire du cinéma c'était déjà faire du
cinéma à la base et bon nimporte quel
genre de cinéma voilà voilà déjà c'était
faire du cinéma et c'est vrai que j'aime
le sexe alors bon on commence par le les
films à caractère pornographique voilà
faire du cinéma ou être filmé pour son
sexe parce que c'est ça surtout quand on
est un homme he c'est ça n'a rien à voir
dans le fond là où je me sens bien c'est
quand je me retrouve avec des caméras
autour de moi tout simplement ça qui est
important ah c'est
oui et vous alors comment vous êtes
arrivé dans dans dans ce métier c'est
c'est tout à fait par hasard on a
accomagnant sur un sur un tournage mais
sans vous étiez tranquillement vous
pensiez à au à le DS voilà je pass au
pyone vous étiez en train de travailler
tranquillement voilà et bon ben il me
dit bah viens avec moi on va on va sur
un tournage tu un peu l'ambiance tout ça
je dis ouais pourquoi pas et euh je suis
arrivé sur sur tournage il a fait sa
scène tout ça et un acteur a eu une
panne et une P une panne une panne
se pas pu continu il av voilà et là le
producteur est venu me voir il m'a
demandé est-ce que ton copain pourrait
faire la scène à la place de cette
personne est-ce qu'il serait capable je
lui dit écoute il en a jamais fait il
peut essayer il a essayé il a tenu la
scène jusqu'au bout voilà on sent que
vous êtes quelqu'un de plutôt timide et
oui quand même j'ai du mal à réserv
moins que vous ah oui moi je suis plus
rentre dedans quoi on va
dire façon de parler bien
sûr et comment vous avez dépassé vous la
timidité la pudeur alors ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que ma partenaire m'a quand
même vachement aidé dans dans ma
première scène elle était quand même
com très douce très gentille et là pour
moi ça compte ça compte en fait vous
êtes très émotif hein ouais ben
c'està-dire qu'il est émotif dans un
certain sens les motifs en haut mais pas
en bas ça je crois que on avait compris
je sais pas ça marché tout seul et puis
je me suis pas vraiment posé de question
quoi c'est un tout c'est de voir c'est
c'est de toucher de même les odeurs moi
ça m'excite alors des fois il suffit de
rien vous ne jouez pas complètement vous
en fait petitf vous n'êtes pas complè
pour l'instant comédien c'est vraiment
vous participez
vraiment et tout de suite après cette
première expérience vous vous vous êtes
dit c'est mon truc allez j'arrête je ne
travaille plus comme donc ouvrier câur
je je deviens comédien de de X vu mon
première expérience j'ai trouvé ça hyper
fun et
puis est très très rigolo alors j'ai dit
pourquoi pas quoi ça cétait il y a un an
voilà d'accord aujourd'hui vous tourz
combien de films soixantaine je sais pas
ouais dans les EOS là voilà c'est dire
vous en vous tournez beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup vous êtes tourne on tourne
voilà et vous ben moi je m'amuse quoi
pour moi c'est un jeu je m'amuse alors
que j'aille faire un film ou que je joue
à la Playstation c'est pareil quoi alors
il paraît qu'on vous appelle vous le
Roco français le nouveau Roco français
le seul truc qui peut se rapprocher de
Roco ouais le seul truc qui peut se
rapprocher ouis je suis d'accord avec
lui je pe terminer ma PHAs vas-y termine
le seul truc qui peut se rapprocher à
Roco c'est pas mon physique mais c'est
peut-être la taille quoi un moment donné
être reconnu connu pour la longueur de
son pénis est-ce que c'est un
aboutissement en
soir Roco il est pas il est pas reconnu
que pour ça quoi bah au
départartc quand même il mérite he cet
homme il mérite il était reconnu d'
d'accord au départ pour pour sa taille
quoi mais c'est surtout par sa façon de
faire quoi et les les positions hein
dans le X sont toujours les mêmes sont
des sont des figures sont pratiquement
toujours les mêmes est-ce que vous les
connaissez parce que vous avez regardé
vous d'abord des films de x que vous
reproduisez est-ce qu'on vous les
apprend et quelle part vous avez-vous
d'innovation peut-être deux ou trois
scènes que que j'ai trouvé original mais
la meilleure scène que j'ai fait jusqu'à
maintenant c'est dans le principe de
plaisir c'està-dire cette position pas
papa maman une scène d'amour une scène
d'amour ça c'est une position que rare
rarement on voit dans il va falloir
bientôt changer de cinéma vous hein vous
êtes sûr vous ne vous êtes pas égaré
dans le dans le hard parce que vous
revenez toujours à l'amour c'est non
c'est vachement c'est c'est très
important pour moi c'est mais il y en a
très peu des films comme ça bah oui
malheureusement de temps en temps vous
vous dites pas là il exagère le
réalisateur ouis des fois il y en a qui
qui pousseent quoi par exemple est-ce
qu'il y a des choses que vous vous avez
refusé de faire vous dites là c'est
c'est trop ah ouais il y a carrément des
trucs genre cracher dans la figure à une
actrice ou
à ou eururos Cato tous ces trucs là
c'est des questions quoi qui sont
courant il le savent quoi et quelles
sont les qualités qui sont demandées au
hardeur en dehors du fait évidemment
qu'il faut avoir une érection qui doit
durer ouais déjà être endurant ouais
endurêre endurant c'est combien d'heures
combien d'heures combien de
temps vous savez on peut faire on peut
faire une scène qui va durer si est bien
mise en boîte on peut faire une scène
qui va durer je dirais 1
heure c'est du mental c'est tout dans la
tête sans rien prendre sans rien prendre
c'est tout dans la tête le VI gr par
exemple le VI à ce qui paraît c'est
franchement pas ceiller quoi les
préservatifs préservatif est-ce que vous
travaillez toujours avec préservatif ou
parfois 100 on travaille avec
préservatif et parfois
alors selon la demande du réalisateur ou
c'est c'est vous qui décidez non selon
la demande du réalisateur mais vous
n'avez pas peur on est on est on est au
niveau médical on est suivi au niveau
médical c'est dire qu'on a nos tests moi
j'ai mes tests depuis que j'ai commencé
j'ai tous mes tests qui suivent et ça on
y fait très très attention moi ce que je
fais je fais un test tous les 3 semaines
pareilou par rapport à votre vie
amoureuse alors lorsque vous lorsque
vous avez commencé
donc il y a un an l'un et l'autre à à
faire du du X vous aviez des des petites
amies vous les avez toujours moi je veux
pas m'embêter avec une femme non j'en
voie j'en j'en ai assez alors attendez
je vous suis vous dites que c'est le
métier donc par ailleurs avoir une
petite copine c'est plutôt du côté des
sentiments pas mais vous n'avez pas
besoin de d'être amoureux donc non non
non non pour l'instant j'en ai j'en ai
pas besoin non alors ça veut dire que
vous vous prenez du plaisir sur le
tournage moi je prends du plaisir sur
les tournages et du plaisir en dehors
des tournages oui et sur les tournages
aussi oui à l'inverse de beaucoup de
filles du du x qui disent qu'elles ne
prennent pas du tout de plaisir il y en
a ou très
rarement monteus il y en a qu' prennent
il y en a on ne citera pas mais il y en
a les filles ont un problème c'est c'est
que elles veulent pas dire j'ai
l'impression que c'est une honte d'avoir
pris du plaisir sur un tournage il y en
a pas beaucoup qui le disent prennent du
plaisir c'est plus beau à la caméra
c'est plus beau pour le tél pour le
spectacteur qui regarde devant son écran
je suis désolé une fille qui joue à la
caméra c'est quand même plus beau qu'une
fille qui simule quoi oui mais enfin
c'est quand même c'est c'est quand même
ça la plupart du temps on dirait que ça
vous vexe tous les deux peut-être parce
que vous êtes jeunes dans le métier mais
que ça vous met en cause votre ça met en
cause votre virilité prère nous on
préfère que de jeun
EUR on préfère moi je dis on préfère que
vous préfériez c'est une chose mais
est-ce que vous vous sentez à dans votre
virilité si on vous dit ça oh ça non je
pense pas parce que moi en de en dehors
en dehors des films j'ai j'ai pas de
problème avec ma copine ça se passe
plutôt bien bah c'est-à-dire que moi
c'est vrai que depuis que je suis je
suis dans le métier ça m'est arrivé C
cet été avec une très très jolie fille
on a fait l'amour et elle me elle m'a
fait comme ça parce qu'elle savait que
que je faisais comme moi je je ne m'en
cache pas je le dis et elle m'a fait
mais tu te crois dans un film
c'est-à-dire que je je on garde des tics
quoi quand on fait l'amour des fois on
on est sur des tics et on nous dit mais
voà c'est un peu embêtant mais je disais
non non mais il y a pas de caméra je
sais qu'il y a pas de caméra on fait
l'amour t'inquiète pas c'estàdire dans
un certain sens je me dis ben maintenant
je vais pas dire que je fais du X comme
ça je seraai
tranquille pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et
actiz la
[Musique]
cloche